y ahora segovia bienvenida a france 24
ante el parlamento la diputada aurora
magdala afirmó que la reparación puede y
tiene que ser un referente para la
defensa de los derechos de las mujeres
usted está de acuerdo con esta
afirmación y cree o no que sea así
claro lo que hicimos nosotros justamente
esta semana en el parlament de catalunya
en realidad es reconocer
institucionalmente una campaña que ya
hace años que hay en cataluña que ha
tenido mucho apoyo social que justamente
lo que pide es reparar a estas mujeres
que hace 300 400 500 años fueron
acusadas injustamente por ser bruja
fueron torturadas fueron asesinadas y
además fueron consideradas culpables por
toda una sociedad lo que hacemos ahora
en el siglo 21 es reconocer que en
realidad esto pueden feminicidio que se
las acusó por ser mujeres por ser
mujeres sabias' por ser mujeres
independientes por tener conocimientos
de cómo cuidar con plantas de cómo
cuidar la salud sexual y reproductiva de
las mujeres y ahora lo que hacemos es
dignificar su memoria a aprender de lo
que pasó y a partir de aquí ser capaces
de enfrentar estas acusaciones de estos
rumores que a veces nos llevan a muchas
mujeres a estar como en exposición
pública
evidentemente salvando las distancias
pero sí que creemos que es necesario
recuperar esa memoria estudiarla y saber
que esto es un hecho que pasó en la
historia europa y en el debate
parlamentario varias colectividades como
box y el pp se opusieron a la medida
asegurando que era irrelevante reparar a
estas mujeres que le respondería usted a
estos partidos
cuando box de una fuerza ultraderecha y
el partido popular nunca tenían sus
prioridades los derechos de las mujeres
tampoco la recuperación de la memoria
histórica también cuando intentamos
reivindicar todas las personas que
fueron asesinadas y torturadas durante
la guerra civil durante el franquismo
ellos creen que no es importante y esto
ahora no toca nosotros creemos que sí
que toca que la recuperación la
reparación de las víctimas de un
feminicidio que afectó a centenares de
mujeres merecen ser tenidas en cuenta
que esto no es incompatible con hablar
de los otros problemas que pasan en la
ciudadanía por suerte los parlamentarios
tenemos la capacidad de hablar de muchos
temas sin que uno sea menor o mayor que
otro y sí que creemos que es necesario
por ejemplo que los estudiantes pues mi
hija que está en sexto de primaria sepa
lo que pasó en esta xxiv a cuando
estudia la edad media estudia los
derechos de los de los campesinos de los
nobles de la iglesia pero no lo que pasó
con las brujas